we've seen some companies that created a
lot of value with non-paying customers
got acquired for very large sums of
money
but ultimately to me if customers are
paying it means they really value
what it is you're delivering
[Music]
lilia sherman thank you so much for
joining me how are you today
great michael thanks for having me of
course where are you calling from
i am uh right in the middle of silicon
valley actually in redwood city
california
in the middle of silicon valley edward
city california so um
today you are the ceo of the sherman
group uh
an expert in go to market and we'll talk
all about that we'll talk about the
difference between go to market and
marketing
and and we have quite a long journey to
get through today but we have to start
all the way back to your first
job in college i believe when you were
wearing a
bunny suit and so it's quite a long
journey from wearing a bunny suit as a
job to
uh being the ceo of a consultancy group
in silicon valley but but take me all
the way back there
and and paint me paint me the picture
sure um so uh this summer
after my junior year in college i
uh got a job uh at applied materials
which is a semiconductor equipment
company
and um the part of the company i worked
with was the
uh what was called final test so it was
where these very large multi-million
dollar machines imagine a
minivan sized piece of equipment with
robotics and gas lines and vacuum
chambers and all kinds of things
going through final tests before they go
out to a semi-nutrifab
and they had to be in a clean room so to
get in there you have to wear what's
called a bunny suit
which is this you know white coverall
because you don't want any extra
particles
and it becomes you know you don't think
about the jargon you use in your
uh job and so once in a while i would
say yeah i spent all day in a bunny suit
and people would kind of look at me like
what what do you what's your job exactly
right and i actually ended up staying
and applied materials for about another
four years
um after graduation they kept me all
through senior year and beyond
uh so yeah that was that's my bunny suit
story and it's not nearly as exciting
i'm sorry as one might think
well it's still a great story so so then
what happens so you're
you're starting out and applied
materials you spend quite a few years
there
mainly wearing a bunny suit and and how
do you end up becoming an
expert and go to market strategy
um so even even then because i was in
this uh
the culmination of all the things that
the company did
uh my job was uh started out being about
quality so all the all the problems we
would find
before we were sending the machines out
to the customer
came from all kinds of different places
whether it was suppliers or assembly
or a faulty part or whatever it may be
um
and so i got a view
really early on into the
interconnectedness of all things into
how all of the different things that
happen along a supply chain contribute
to the final
product and so while still at applied
materials i
applied to stanford graduate school got
in
applied was kind enough to give me a
fellowship to do that
um so that was the first step in what i
call the journey to the dark side
um i did a really cool program that was
in the engineering school but had a lot
of business school
pieces to it um and uh
a funny side story about that my
master's project
the the class produced what is the
gorilla pod
which is that little stand for cameras
made out of little balls
okay so that was the winning team and we
were the runners-up
wow um and so
uh coming out of stanford i got
recruited by accenture
which is one of the big consulting firms
their strategy practice
right um and did supply chain strategy
for several years so what does that mean
supply chain strategy like what what i'm
imagining in the day today you have to
talk to a
you have to really like sit in front of
a huge map and think about what are the
different opportunities to go
to get the the products across how does
that actually look like
so some of it is optimization how many
warehouses where
how many you know which factories the
distribution network
some of it is more broad we did quite a
bit of acquisition
uh work uh the uh compact
uh deck uh acquisition
uh ascend and um
cascade merged which i always thought
was funny because the two names were
exactly opposites um so it was you know
bringing together operations of
different companies
um i i think a better really descriptor
for what we were doing was operational
strategy
wasn't just really supply chain and
logistics um
although you know some clients had
accenture doing that as well so
it was sort of a nice segue between my
very geeky engineering background
uh and sort of looking at it from a
business perspective
and so i kind of call my time and
accenture my uh
you know if i if the mba wasn't the
title of my masters then that those
three years definitely
from there i ended up doing um
something i knew absolutely nothing
about and i joke that that's
i like to every five or six years go and
start
something new that i know nothing about
and learn it and then go do something
else
so after accenture i went to
bea systems which is a software company
and i had no idea
about anything to do with software i
went into a product marketing role
i had no idea about marketing um the
reason i ended up there is because
they were diversifying away from their
core technology into areas
that required an understanding of why
integrating data and systems and so on
would matter to a customer and that i
understood
so yeah so they took a chance and they
hired uh you know
what i thought was a kind of unqualified
person and it was a blast
it was a blast to do something really
new it sounds completely fascinating and
i'd love to i'd love to transition and
discuss a little bit about
the the idea behind go-to-market
strategies
a a hundred percent you know we're
seeing so many different emerging
markets today so many emerging
technologies
that i get that i get to observe both as
a student at stanford from the
engineering side but also
as a member of j ventures from the uh
from the investment side and one of the
key questions is always how do you bring
the product out
to the audience and not in terms of
marketing but how do you actually
what is it what is the what is the chain
like to get there
and it's obviously it's called it's a
common question for a small startup and
for a big enterprise
can you start lilia by explaining to me
what is go to market fundamentally
and and why is it such a crucial aspect
and then allude to
how your firm helps companies
optimize that yeah
so i define go to market very broadly
um to me it's pretty much everything a
company does to get its
product out in front of paying customers
right
uh why not why is that an important
piece of it
because if you don't have paying
customers eventually you run out of cash
and
can't do whatever magic it is you want
to do right fundamentally
and yes we've we've seen some companies
that created a lot of value with
non-paying customers got acquired for
very large sums of money
but ultimately to me if customers are
paying it means they really value
what it is you're delivering okay right
and i'm also assuming that
the reason that that word is in there is
because the strategy is inherently
different
a way to acquire a a free customer is
very different than
acquiring a paying customer right it's
maybe a different demographic different
strategy
and different friction to get there
yeah absolutely absolutely uh
and uh and of course it's different
between uh
business customers and consumers as well
right right um
yeah and and my focus has definitely
been on on the business side but i think
a lot of the
um the ways that
we think about delivering value and
uh unifying everything you do that's
customer facing
is very relevant to both consumers and
businesses right
and so when i when i think about go to
market
for younger companies you know there's
always when you're pitching to investors
um there's always this slide you're told
you have to have a go to market slide
and a lot of founders really struggle
with that
because they're thinking we don't know
yet
right we're early or uh they don't have
that expertise on the team
and so that that size probably has the
the largest variation i've seen in terms
of something that makes sense and
something that's just clearly
pulled out of the air you know in the
last as an afterthought to the rest of
the presentation
um there are three parts when i think
about go to market there's sort of the
strategy and the fundamental thing the
fundamental decision is
who are we serving and what problem are
we solving for them
that's that's really really simple right
and that's something that you should at
least have a uh
you know a good idea of or a good thesis
about
when you start out right um and then the
questions that follow are things like
what
by what means are we solving that
problem and what are we going to what
mode are we going to build around it
that's defensible long term
right those four questions at a
startup level is what you need to answer
as you grow then you get into planning
and content and value propositions and
you know marketing strategy and
alliances and
all the other things that make up go to
market uh but at the beginning
those four questions who what are we
doing for them
how are we doing it and how are we going
to keep this
wow and unique are the four things you
really need to
to think about right so uh so it makes
perfect sense that this
strategy changes you know on a
on a very regular basis as the product
is changing as the team and the and the
world is obviously changing your
strategy should be changing
is this is something that you recommend
thinking from the get-go as you're
building the product already
understanding
this is the strategy of how i'm gonna
get it to the customer or or is this at
a later stage
when when does it really become a
crucial part of the company
and this go to market
so i think of it in stages right when
you were first starting to conceive the
product those two questions
of what problem and for whom are going
to be really important because they
influence how you design the product
they influence um how the user interacts
with it
they influence how much you have to plan
to invest in
sales and post sales support how you're
going to reach
that customer there's a lot of
decisions that cascade down from those
few right and so i would say start
thinking about that
really early because it's going to
influence how much cash you need and
you know who your competitors are and so
on so uh i would say from the get-go
and then and then you you're gonna find
you're gonna iterate you know your
packaging
pricing is gonna change uh a lot of
things are gonna change but you've gotta
have that pieces early
so the next question that i have is you
know i'm thinking of myself
creating a startup in a few months with
some really great friends from stanford
from the army wherever
you know we're going to be sitting
around we are we're going to build
hopefully a great product and none of us
have
any experience in supply chains and go
to market strategies and
and even thinking about what it takes to
bring a product there and obviously you
know when we're
two weeks old or two months old we're
probably not going to bring an
outside executive to come and do our go
to market strategy from the get go
so how do you balance your lack of
experience
with the need to have some strategy
playing out
uh it's it's a really easy thing you go
talk to customers
right they they will tell you um
don't don't ever try to do any piece of
go-to-market
even the really early guesses in a you
know
between the four walls um the best thing
that a team can do
is just you know go really understand
uh the customers you think you'll have
um
talk to them about what problem you know
ask a lot of questions
um they will tell you right you don't
need an outside expert you don't need to
hire an expensive cmo
whatever it may be just go validate
validate and then go validate again
right so one of the things that we said
earlier is that
there is a clear distinction between go
to market and marketing and that's
something that
i guess is often you know confused
between the two that your marketing
strategy is not the
is not necessarily the go to market
strategy and vice versa right
i would say go to market is just a
broader set of decisions
okay uh marketing you know i
i joke that the m word should be
actually banned
because it means so many different
things right right
um but ultimately marketing
typically is about generating demand for
your product
um but there are a lot of other things
that impact the customer experience i'll
give you an example look at apple
computer
apple computer you know when steve jobs
started he understood instinctively
that it's not just about the
functionality of the computer it's about
the experience it's about the interface
it's about the packaging
when you know later on when they open
stores it was about
every single very every single thing
within that store
right so uh it's you know the marketing
are
the amazing ads uh the word of mouth
uh and so on but go to market is
everything it's the decision of how
you're gonna distribute
the decision of having an apple expert
within a
um you know best buy store for example
right
um there's a lot of things around it
that
you know it's kind of how to build an
ecosystem
uh of partners and developers that's all
part of go to market
who holds the responsibility of the go
to market strategy within an
organization
even as it scales to tens of thousands
of people who holds that responsibility
so i think it's usually the
chief marketing officer okay but it
really is
an executive team discussion because you
have
strategic alliances and products and so
on that also have to be very engaged a
customer experience now is usually a
separate function
wonderful so there's so many more topics
that we can discuss but i also want to
make sure to to hear a little bit about
the book that you wrote
and some more insights that you've
gained from that before i ask you my
favorite question
of the interview yeah
um so the book i wrote is 42 rules for
growing enterprise revenue
and it's really 42 and you know if
you're a fan of
douglas adams you know why 42. yeah so
i-42
because it's the answer to life the
universe and everything yep
the meaning of life um
so it's a distillation really of the
uh thinking processes and frameworks
that i had used uh
both in my you know operational roles
and with clients
okay and it was a great opportunity to
kind of think through
how do i think about solutions how do i
think about selecting markets how do i
think about
um relationships with customers and
customer relevance and value
um so it's a very you know each rule is
like two pages it's a really quick read
there's a lot of different frameworks in
there
and it was a lot of fun to write i'm
sure was there a specific trigger to
writing it did you see some pattern
forming
or is this mainly insights that you've
gained over the years that you just had
to put on paper
and send it to the world
well the trigger was the publisher
approached me and said write a book
okay my first response was
yeah it's a great trigger um and they
already had uh
kind of a format you know that you had
to follow i don't know that i would have
written it quite that way
um i just started from scratch but uh
it actually you know when you have to
provide an idea
in whatever it is 600 were you know two
two small pages you get very very
focused on
the core everything a hundred percent i
have to you know sell assumption to
reflect back i i recently launched a
book about
youth entrepreneurship and some personal
experiences there was no you know word
limit there was no structure
and it was it was a very interesting
experience very different i guess that
for me was just playing a blank page
just write the story and then condense
it to sound good
and now that i now that you're
mentioning this word limit i almost
wish i had imposed a word limit on
myself so that i could even condense it
more and feel that i'm focusing more on
these ideas
and but it's really great and that and
the book is available i'm guessing on
amazon to purchase
yeah yeah it's uh any any online
bookstore
wonderful okay so the 42 rules i i'm
excited to take a look at it myself
lilia i want to thank you for being so
generous with your time thank you for
sharing your insights both about your
journey
from the bonnie suit all the way to the
sherman group and and your expertise
on on selecting markets and go to market
strategy and in general
how companies work and operate uh i'm
i'm
um these are this is exactly why i'm
doing this show to learn from from
experts like yourself that have been
have seen so much
uh that you know a lot of them a lot of
the mistakes that you've perhaps
observed or the successes you've
observed as a young entrepreneur i can
now take that those lessons with me
and hopefully make less of them on my
journey
so thank you for that and before we
leave i have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself
oh so this was uh you gave me warning
and it was still hard
yeah um it's not a single word but i
would say short attention span
short attention span i like it
um i'd say i'm pretty creative
and uh even though i'm creative
uh very structured i i like to
create boxes and inner relationships and
make very complex things
um conceivable so short attention span
creative and structured i think those
are and that's a fantastic combination
lilia thank you very very much
uh thank you for the inspiration and
stay safe and stay healthy
thank you
hey